[Music]
so we will talk about the annual
reporting like what is what this is and
what issues we face there and we will
highlight the data-driven approach that
is actually the solution to our problems
and we will tell you about architecture
of the application and then we will deep
dive into the sentiment and readability
analysis and then we will close up with
some future work to be done to this tool
so we will switch now to the dialogue
modes hey Jonah thanks for having me I
really need your help because I'm an
auditor and I need to report or review
many reports in a very little time and
any report is actually like a
comprehensive overview of the
performance of a company which should
give a meaningful and balanced overview
of what the company has achieved in a
year and I'm the one that should check
that and this is a very manual arbitrary
task at the moment because I don't have
any tools to help me I just need to read
through this report myself and this is
pretty time-consuming yeah and you have
different versions I guess all the time
I have different versions all the time
it's not that there's one annual report
to refill but the yeah report has a
moving target which is also one of the
bottlenecks so actually we do not know
where we go but we know that we want to
achieve the best result so over and over
we try to improve versions of this
report until we think it's ready for
sign-off and yeah another bottleneck
that I face is that it becomes available
to me very late in the process which
gives me very little time to meet the
deadline and the report is well here it
says over 80 pages well actually the
average annual report is currently I
think over 100 pages so you can imagine
that my my smart brain which is like not
lucky has difficulties with reading
through all these pages in one night and
then also think yeah and say something
about this sure we are currently
building a tool basically with
off-the-shelf libraries and we tested
quite a few that are already there
many sentiment analysis and read
which I think this can provide you a
little bit more information of what you
currently have it can be quite helpful
but we also need your help during the
process since we are trying to build our
own to train our own model we don't have
enough data set because annual reporting
it's already that it's already being
published they're already corrected and
they are already a little bit neutral so
doing this process of you analyzing
annual report through our tool we
actually need your feedback as well to
improve our model but we are going
through a diet driven approach so if we
switch to our own logic of our how we
come up with this tool basically is that
we want to build the culture that acts
upon data so the entire idea is that the
business has so much information all the
time that they're there being fed with a
lot of PDF reports and all this
information is not big used currently
but this can be very helpful for us and
also for you to actually ease a little
bit all the job that you guys are doing
and make your working hours less that's
not good not get you out of job but yes
because actually I just need something
that takes out the subjectivity of our
analysis because currently we are with a
lot of consultants all reading these
reports and giving our opinion and
feedback to the clients yet yeah we
would like a tool to help is to make it
less subjective and maybe that is
something that your tool can help with
as well yes
so let me guide you a little bit through
sentiment analysis I guess you guys
already know what it is about so
differently known as an opinion mining
it's basically an automated process of
understanding an opinion it can be
considered so how we approach this issue
is that if we try to model it as a
classification problem so you have the
subjectivity classification and the
polarity classification the subjectivity
I guess everybody knows it's like if an
opinion is based on facts or not and
according to all the data that we have I
think that we can actually reach that
and polarity so polarities about how
positive or negative it is but how this
will help us is that based on some
research papers that we actually read at
the beginning there were like 60 to 65%
of the time where
judging a sentiment on a particular
piece 60 to 65 people basically agree
upon the same thing we had a lot of test
cases in previous presentations as well
when we saw that not the entire room was
a hundred percent sure on value of the
sentiment of of a sentence also using a
centralized sentiment analysis system
will help us not only in Netherlands but
also through our entire company to
actually analyse better of the reports
well that sounds promising yeah let me
as a software developer that I am I
really like to build applications that
are reliable fast and very well error
prone basically so I will guide you a
little bit on the architecture of the
application that we built and after that
we can go in the juicy part of
readability and sentiment analysis
basically our application right now it's
hosted in Azure we have a dashboard
application which basically shows all
the information that we have we are
using service bus and we have an
analyzer app the analyzer app is
basically our core application which
analyzes all the information you can
trigger different analysis and since we
didn't have a lot of information
according to what we wanted to achieve
like sentiment readability or complexity
we try to build the plug-and-play
architecture and this is why we have the
analyzer app so we want to test
different analysis basically and since
the business rules they are changing
constantly and maybe we can add more
then we wanted to have something that
would allow us to actually increase the
number of analysis that we want to apply
in report
well good thanks and yeah let's talk
about what text and text analytics
actually is so this is the high overview
of what we did and it's currently
working and it's already being used by
our internal users mostly so text
analytics is just a big data dashboard
but not with 400 charts or anything like
that we try to make it try to improve a
little bit the UX you're gonna see a lot
of
little bit squishy shots because we
weren't allowed to actually show it life
it shows the sentiment analysis
subjectivity readability score and also
what cloud which was like something
added at the last minute but this is
based on of the shelf libraries so if I
want to go through the sentiment and
readability now the libraries that we
are using and what we actually tested to
achieve this well it's not good it's
going to be a little bit technical but I
think it's going to be useful especially
also for the business it would be it was
very helpful to explain to the clients
what we're actually doing the sentiment
analysis we started with the simple of
the Scheldt because we didn't as I said
we were software developers and our data
scientists were is coming later in the
scene we started with NLT cave order and
text blog we compared those two more or
less we went through the entire in a
small database not a very big one so the
NLT cavada was performing faster then
actually takes blip but while we put all
the data and regard the information we
saw that text log was more accurate on
positive comments so I know that both of
them they are trained in social media
posts but in this case in our report
part we saw that also a lot of reports
at the beginning when they were uploaded
by the clients there were a lot of
positive reaction about their outcome
and wanted to reduce that so we wanted
to leave about a little bit more natural
and textbook was actually performing
quite good but we wanted the business
help in this case so what we actually
did in our platform is that we allowed
all our internal users to say if there
is a possible if it is positive if it is
a negative sentence based on what we
were providing them so we were already
analyzing with text blog they were
already going through all the
information that they were seeing and
they were just agreeing or not if that
information is correct so if they would
see for example something a sentence
that was provided by text
that was actually positive don't say
like this is not correct this negative
this we would save that information and
in this case we actually did our own
data set that data set we are trying to
switch now to space him because now all
our scientists are involved and we have
we are building a nice data all the
information is already saved and we
attacked all the data more or less it's
still ongoing why we change - space him
this was very well it wasn't a easy
choice but also wasn't a hard choice
we searched about specie and n LT k
because we were doubting because between
those two but since we are having a
really we have really nice data
scientists and they are working to train
their own models they have different
approaches upon that so in case for us
to test our models but also to see which
one were more relevant we wanted someone
like it's not kind of a framework but an
NLP library to actually help us to test
those models and SPC has real nice
architecture behind it so it allows you
to actually attach a lot of attributes
and properties and methods to the dark
objects and token it has an object
oriented approach which we'll love very
much because it actually gets your text
and then it analyzes it and then it
provides you with a dark object and if
you see over there in the entire in the
graph over there so it token eise's it
then it takes it parses and then it
actually provides you a lot of
information right now we actually do
tests between specie tagging and google
tagging that i'll show you in a bit but
first let me show you that how how easy
it is to actually add attributes or
properties in the doc object in specie
and this is just a simple one like the
simplest version ever in ipython
that allows you to actually add all the
possible functions as a sentimental or
you can name them whatever you want but
it adds it as an extension also it
allows us to have a really good
connection with tensorflow as well and
also to test it with different models
that our data scientists are already
training is over here we have basically
a test that we did with Google NLP which
is already available online and with
specie taking and with PC version 2 this
has improved a lot because they're
already working with neural network and
well if you see over here in the green
one it's Alexa which is a product
according to Spacey and in the part over
here which is the Google NLP it ran it
renders Alexa as a person so this was
not the kind of thought taking that you
actually wanted so that's why specie was
way better because actually it compares
to the to the word that actually Alexa
has close by and well this is about
sentiment so far let's switch to
readability so bad readability analysis
this was another of the GRE tensions
it's one of the standards that we use to
audit annual reports which requests for
the reliability and assessment so that
is why we asked an analysis for it as
well of course yes and this was this one
through a lot of research as well we
finished after we did some of our
testing through some of the angle
reports which I think you can see the
names in the graph over there so
Greenpeace Volkswagen PwC Facebook we
saw that actually Fogg was performing a
little bit better we also tested this
with some of the user some of the users
so basically we told our co-workers and
people that we know to actually read
them and more or less give us an idea
how difficult was for them to actually
to read and go through these reports we
decided about the Ghanim fog index you
can see the formula there it's not a
hard formula and we already had all the
data to actually calculate it we don't
do it ability test for touch languages
yet but there is something that is going
to come in the future great well thank
you for explaining all these analysis to
us and to me I'm really happy that this
is possible and I also told you in the
beginning that we need like those
different versions so would it be
possible to include it in the tool that
we could see differences between the
first second and so on versions of the
annual reports did we are able to track
like the differences and if the import
yet the reports actually improves in
quality so as we said this is an
application and we allow our clients to
log in and we allow our internal users
to log in and then can upload the not
the final version of the PDF report yet
the historic view is one of the
additions that we had recently and well
it requires a little bit of work because
we built our own algorithm it's a really
real simple rule based algorithm to see
if there are like two paragraphs that
two paragraphs are similar to each other
or not or if there was a new add
paragraph or a sentence so basically is
to define what is different between two
PDF reports and this will resolve it
pretty good actually because we tested
it with multiple juries with multiple
reports so far and I guess that it was
you could actually see the difference
and you could actually see if there was
like a new report edit or a new
paragraph edit or new sentences and if
there were like an editing between those
two and I guess this helps your job as
well yes grace well actually I would
like to see some examples of how
how this tool would display the results
of the analysis to me because currently
I do not really have the idea of how
this would translate into a tool because
it's all a very nice story that of
course how does it look like in reality
yes so the application the part that we
spend some time on making it easy for
people to understand if you see over
here there is a graph of sentiment
analysis which well we get the PDF and
we're using PDF to tree to actually
separate it in paragraphs and in titles
and in chapters so we you can here you
can see basically all the chapters and
of the PDF
it's way longer than this because the
reports are more than 100 pages
sometimes but you can actually see the
current the comparison between the
current version and the previous version
and right now in this example it's not
there but if there is a new paragraph
edit then you could see only the current
version the current value of that
paragraph or of that chapter it looks a
little bit weird because I've erased
some of the names of the client that we
tested this upon but you get the idea
also you have the filtering the
filtering would help you to actually get
the sentiment values on the paragraph
also on the sentence and this is the
part that we actually needed the help of
business they were actually giving us a
lot of data and marking if that
information was correct or not and
that's how we're actually building our
own label database if you go this goes
for the sentiment analysis also for the
readability so in the readability graph
we actually showed through the Gannet
fog index we also explained it for the
users because this platform is being
used by our internal users but also by
clients currently well the one thing
that I forgot to mention is that the
analyst analysis happens on fly so in
the moment that you upload the report we
start we trigger our task and then you
could actually see the readability score
the sentiment and everything
subjectivity while it's being calculated
so we are dated constantly right now for
news
like an 80 pages report with using text
blog for the moment it's not it's taking
around 5 minutes or so which is like
pretty good and it helps the user to the
users our internal users but also the
clients will actually see the
information right away this is the
readability as I said we explain what
we're using and how we are using it also
the subjectivity is more or less the
same yeah so that would be the next is
similar to the sentiment analysis so it
also works with chapters and you can
click through because the high scores
are of course the most interesting to
view because you want to know like the
most objective paragraphs of text and
see whether that's actually the right
thing to do or whether it should be more
objectively formulated so then you would
go into the chapter and then in the
chapter you see there are different
paragraphs and like the top three are
the ones which have like the highest
subjectivity score so we could zoom in
on those paragraphs and actually reads
what's in there and then see if the
subjectivity is correctly used or not
because sometimes you really have effect
based text but you could also have for
instance like a very objective display
of Brazil so then you do not want to
have so much yeah subjectivity in it
because then the client could really
steer the minds of the users of the
annual report but then that's not yeah
according to the standards so yeah let's
see what's our next slides Oh surprise
surprise the surprise analysis this was
like a present that we had from
experience center in our analysis it's
just simple word clouds which basically
shows the most common used in well I've
erased the last one I hope you don't
understand the client but well it's
mostly more or less like all the words
that are being used mostly for the
moment we also remove the text so it's
just a lorem ipsum one because it
explains like how often the words are
and also mainly like
where can you find them in the text so
this is this was for showcase purposes
well great thanks a lot for the
presentation of all the analysis of
course there's always room for further
development so we just wanted to guide
you through what we will do to improve
this to even further yes yeah so the
first thing that I was thinking of us
that I actually also find I think it's
interesting for the client to see how
they perform compared to their
competitors so it would be nice if in
the future we could build in a option
that this is possible do you think this
might work
yes actually we're currently working on
that but yeah it's still on the under
progress okay and let's see how that
works out yeah also the part of we
wanted to improve our library to extract
from PDFs to get information from
pictures as well because sometimes they
include a lot of pictures with a lot of
information in these annual reports and
no we actually want to have the data as
well to analyze it we want we are
currently training our models and we
want it by attaching it as a property to
space see objects but yeah we are we are
still under progress on that we'll keep
you updated Thanks yeah and then the
final a present that we received from
you the word clouds was a great surprise
but we think we could use something more
specific because currently yeah okay
five minutes thanks Oh ten okay great
we have the words that prevail the most
an annual report but it would be even
more interesting to see which topics
reveal the most because companies are
reporting on material topics that they
identify in our materiality matrix and
of course it would be weird if there are
other topics prevailing more in any
report than the topics that they should
report on based on their materiality
matrix so we thought we heard something
about topic modeling maybe most of you
already know
exactly what this is but this is quite
new to me and I hope that Altona could
help me with building this into the tool
as well so that we get really verify
whether the topics that are material to
the company are the ones that are
highlighted in the report the most yes
this is something that we are actually
thinking on and we're working up on it
but as I said our models are into
training because we just were just for
the moment labeling our database and the
business is helping with that so these
are like future work that you want to do
with the application itself but right
now I guess it's quite nice and
successful with the information that we
got so far and I guess helpful thank you
yeah it really is and thank you all for
listening to us thank you
[Applause]